pas facile de situer vos positions
vous étiez au centre droit avec françois
bayrou et puis votre position sur
l'europe est devenue moins clair vous
avez voté contre le mariage pour tous
contre la pma vous avez revêtu un gilet
jaune on l'a vu et vous êtes allés aussi
soutenir le mouvement d'extrême gauche
nuit debout
plus qu'un mouvement c'est un petit
village de la contestation avec son
concert forcément gratuit et sa cantine
à prix libre les gens donnent ce qu'ils
veulent mais parce que aussi d'une
certaine conception des choses
les gens sont pas forcément on est
obligé de donner quoi c'est mieux mais
patrick bao chose
ils ont voulu inscrire l'état d'urgence
dans la constitution c'est à dire qu'ils
sont en train de mettre en place tous
les outils du fascisme je dirais
beaucoup de rage mais aussi une bonne
dose d'utopie avec le mauvais temps le
rassemblement fait un peu réunion de
famille d'extrême gauche et c'est tout
le problème qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
construire entré chez moi j'ai demandé à
mes potes nous dit-on devenir erreur je
peux vraiment des amis voisins nos
militants de venir devraient demander un
des amis de la famille peut-être
on a du mal à vous suivre jean lassalle
centre droite gauche où êtes vous y at
il un la salle isme
oui excusez moi je me suis suffisamment
musclée cheville pour pouvoir vous
répondre mais venant à l'exemple
précédent mais général de gaulle est ce
que vous ne passez pas qu'il a été un
peu difficile à suivre lui aussi parfois
aller le josé compris regardez ce qui
s'en est suivie dans les quatre ans qui
ont
suivi la faire
regardez
le de vol du second mandat et regardez
ameutant le fait qu'il a été
il a pu tenir le conseil national de la
résistance avec le parti communiste avec
la somme des parties qui avaient
participé à
la résistance qu'il a été très proche et
du maréchal pétain avec thil s'était
ensuite vous riez à tout jamais le
marché le pétain qui a été affirmé en
vallée d'aspe dont vous parliez tout à
l'air fort du portalet tout comme il y
avait été enfermé dans la dié et toute
l'équipe de l'unfp qu est ce que vous
pensez qu'il était facile à suivre je
crois qu'un homme qui a l'intuition
qui aime passionnément ce pays et qui le
sang et conduit à avoir des attitudes et
des rencontres successives et c'est la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui avec
résistants j'ai voulu me mettre en
position de rassembler ce grand pays ça
ne durera pas longtemps mais nous avons
besoin de le faire car vous voyez le
monde tragique dans lequel nous vivons
je le décris depuis 30 ans depuis 30 ans
seulement deux mois comment s'est moqué
de lui peut-être que maintenant on
n'acceptera pour mes dernières sorties
de bien vouloir lire un peu ce que
j'écrivais il ya déjà trente ans et qui
n'est pas tellement différent de ce qui
se passe et résistant c'est un vrai
parti avec des locaux des militants mais
là sa liste oui et je dirais beaucoup
d'abstentionnistes
voyez vous c'est à dire des hommes et
les femmes qui ont voté passionnément
pour les plus anciens
il ya beaucoup de jeunes et de femmes de
gauche
qui ont déterré dans les mains
socialiste plutôt à gauche vous voyez il
ya quelques semaines dentiste il ya des
communistes il ya des gaullistes
l'incontestable m'a fait ce qu'un petit
c'est vrai mais les sympathisants et dix
mille adhérents en quatre ans c'est pas
non plus le perron
[Musique]